Behind me on the launchpad is
Artemis one.
It's the first step in NASA's
ambitious program to bring American
astronauts back to the moon for the
first time in half a century
and then on to Mars.
Assuming NASA can pull it off, which
is a big question mark, is the
project worth hundreds of billions
of government money?
Is NASA just trying to relive the
glory of the Apollo mission?
Will private companies take us back
to the Moon and Mars, faster and
cheaper?
Artemis is the latest in a long
series of setbacks and reversals in
America's space program.
In 2010, President Obama
announced the shelving of the
Constellation program, which was
NASA's last attempt to bring
astronauts back to the moon.
The following year, the agency shut
down its space shuttle program
altogether because of costs and
safety concerns.
Obama also announced that NASA's
would begin relying more on private
contractors.
I recognize that some have said it
is unfeasible or unwise to work
with the private sector in this way.
I disagree.
But six years later, the Trump
administration greenlit the Artemis
program, which was heralded as the
beginning of a new space exploration
renaissance at NASA.
It marks an important step in
returning American astronauts
to the moon for the first time
since 1972.
This directive will ensure America's
space program once again leads and
inspires all of humanity.
The pioneer spirit has always
defined America.
Artemis one, the unmanned test
route that traveled 1.4 million
miles through space, splashed down
on December 12th.
And that's just the first of four
planned launches.
Artemus II will bring humans into
space and Artemis III, scheduled
to launch in 2025, is supposed
to bring humans to the moon with
help from Space X's starship
vehicle.
After that, NASA's planning nearly
Artemis launches.
And liftoff of Artemis one.
We rise together back
to the moon and beyond.
That's the plan.
Artemis I's first three attempts at
liftoff were canceled because of
leaking issues connected to the
rocket's crown system.
The Artemis I mission postponed
for the second time this week due to
technical issues.
The rocket finally went airborne on
November 16, 2022.
The price tag was $4.1 billion,
and the next three launches are
expected to each cost about the
same. NASA's auditor estimates
that the Artemis program will spend
$93 billion by 2025.
Because of delays.
It's unlikely that a human will make
it back to the moon by the end of
2024, as originally planned.
From 1960 to 1973
NASA's spent 280
billion in today's dollars on
moon landings, but the agency
remains one of America's most
popular, according to opinion polls,
alongside the National Park Service
and, surprisingly, the U.S.
Postal Service.
Beating the Soviets to the moon
bolstered America's claim to
technological and ideological
superiority in the 20th century.
That's one small step for man,
one giant leap for
mankind.
But ever since Neil Armstrong's one
small step, there have been giant
leaps in space transportation made
in large part by the private sector.
Oh, wow.
Liftoff of the satellite
and crew Dragon. Go NASA, go SpaceX.
In 2009, the private sector saw
one of its biggest champions ascend
to become the number two person at
NASA. Lori Garver pushed to describe
the Constellation program as a way
to entice the private sector to fill
in the gaps.
She also spearheaded the commercial
crew program, which continues to
employ commercial contractors to
ferry astronauts to the
International Space Station.
Today, companies like Elon Musk's
SpaceX Are launching rockets at a
faster pace and for a fraction
of what NASA's spends.
"What we're seeing in short is the
beginning of a historic transfer of
space operations from the public to
the private sector," wrote then
Reason editor Bob Poole.
That was in the magazine's April
1979 issue.
Poole, who has always been ahead of
the curve on issues related to space
and privatization, is now Reason
Foundation's director of
transportation policy.
In the magazine's December 2022
issue, he wrote about how science
fiction writer Robert Heinlein's
dream of private space travel is
coming true.
Commercial space transport is the
obvious future, and I think we're
we're getting well on the way to it.
After the Artemis program.
Former politician and current Nassau
chief Bill Nelson argues that space
travel is a function that must be
carried out by the government.
Space is a very unforgiving
kind of environment, and NASA
has always run
the programs
being built by contractors,
not contractors running
the programs.
With oversight of NASA.
Now that's a new way of doing
business.
Back when Nelson made those remarks,
commercial space transport was still
nascent.
More than a decade later, private
space companies have proven
themselves to be more competent and
cost effective than NASA.
Does NASA still need to be in the
space travel business at all?
The moon is really a stepping stone.
We really need to learn how to live
and work on the moon before we ever
go to Mars.
And that's the whole reason of the
Artemis program.
Lily Villareal is a NASA engineer
who works on the Artemis team.
She says that exploring the cosmos
is critical to the long term
preservation of the human race,
making it a valid use of public
funds.
I really think it's important to go
to deep space and learn how to live
in deep space because we have
limited resources here on Earth.
We eventually are going to
become a society where we have
to move beyond
Earth to be able to live.
She says that Artemis' price tag
is justified by the need for NASA
to be safe and thorough.
This is the first time we are
actually putting this rocket
together, and so we always expected
challenges.
One of the things about NASA's we
test like you fly.
We want to make sure that we get it.
Right. Because this you know, we
want this wants to be successful.
It's a test flight.
So we're doing everything possible
that we can to make sure that we are
ready to go. And really we won't go
into we are ready to go.
The biggest criticism of the
project. Is the cost.
How do you respond to that type of
criticism?
It's an investment in
to our civilization about
our ability to learn how to go
to deep space and live in deep
space, which is something right now
we don't have the capability to do.
I believe that this nation should
commit itself to achieving
the goal before this
decade is out of landing
a man on the moon and returning him
safely to the earth.
No single space project in this
period will be more impressive
to mankind, or more important
for the long range exploration of
space.
And none will be so difficult
or expensive to accomplish.
The space race was also a way of
demonstrating America's military
dominance over the Soviet Union,
which had embarrassed the U.S.
with the 1957 launch of Sputnik,
the first artificial Earth
satellite, NASA and its
political backers seem determined to
recapture the glory of the Apollo
missions, with Artemis.
Poole says that the agency tends to
stick to old ways of doing things
isn't particularly interested
in cost savings and its decision
making is overly driven by politics.
Basically, it's designed to repeat
the Apollo program.
The hardware that powered Artemus I
is known as the SLS, the Space
Launch System, and was developed in
partnership with Boeing.
Critics have another name for it.
The Senate Launch System, because it
was concocted by the Senate as a
way to rescue Constellation, give
it a new name.
Paul says NASA would have been
better off replacing the costly and
dated space launch system used in
the Artemis program.
But it didn't, which probably has a
lot to do with the fact that it was
largely constructed and engineered
in Alabama, the home state of Senate
Appropriations Chair Richard Shelby,
who has a history of strong arming
NASA's to preserve jobs for his
constituents.
In 2019, the Senate earmarked
$2.58 billion
as a starting point to cover the
space launch systems ballooning
price tag.
The Senate funding also required
NASA to make use of old warehouse
materials from Constellation,
ostensibly a cost saving measure.
Well, it turns out after sitting in
the warehouse, each one has to be
refurbished at about 150
million per engine.
There's four of them in SLS.
And so it's $600 million just
to refurbish the used
all tech engines for every
single launch.
For four years in a row under two
different administrations.
NASA's got more money from Congress,
then the president requested.
The human spaceflight program
of this country can only be
led by the elected leader of
this country because he set the
priorities, he is going
to have to
pony up,
inhibit his Office of
the Management and Budget, more
money.
The biggest boondoggle in the
industry right now is the space
launch system.
The Constellation program and
the space shuttle were both canceled
around 2011.
And senators in Alabama,
Texas and Florida wanted to keep the
jobs associated with those programs
even after the cancelations.
And so they created a derivative
rocket program and told NASA to
do it.
Eli Dourado is an economist at the
Center for Growth and Opportunity at
Utah State University, who studies
regulation of the commercial space
industry.
He says the SLS is largely a jobs
program that utilizes wasteful
cost plus contracts that
require NASA to fully cover a
project's expenses, plus an extra
fee as profit, eliminating any
risk taken on by the contractor.
There's no incentive to find
cost savings.
NASA's Bill Nelson has called cost
plus contracting "a plague."
Dourado says NASA's entire rocket
program should be outsourced to
private companies like SpaceX and
Blue Origin, who bid to complete the
work at a fixed cost.
The commercial approach
is to
create a market for the service
that you want to buy
and let hungry competitors
work to get the cost down and the
performance up.
NASA's has some smart
scientists and some smart engineers,
but it's a huge bureaucracy and it's
very, very risk averse.
Paul refers to NASA's cumbersome
rocket design process as the one
best way approach, in contrast
to private firms, which are always
on the lookout for more innovative
and cost effective ways of doing
things. SpaceX has engineered
a way to land its boosters after use
instead of disposing of them into
the ocean, as NASA does.
Paul remembers the first time he saw
Space X's method in action.
There came the boosters coming down
beautifully, settling down
right on target pads.
And I thought, 'Oh my God, this is
incredible.' And the thought that
immediately came to mind was, 'My
God, Robert Heinlein should be alive
today to see this'.
He wrote the first science fiction
story ever that I know of about
private enterprise, creating
a rocket vehicle to launch
boom crystallized
me how important the business
approach to space launch has become.
Space X has recovered 32 boosters
that have all been reused at least
one time for the Falcon nine and
Falcon heavy launch vehicles.
One booster has even flown 14
times.
The company is pushing to get that
number up to 30 while
Artimus one's launch costs $4
billion. The average launch of space
x's falcon heavy runs between 100
and 150 million, with enough
capacity to carry about 80%
of Artimus' load.
It seems that SpaceX is still on
their way to perfecting that
reusability element for
rocket boosters.
But the SLS system, like you said,
is not reusable.
Why did NASA go that route of less
reusability?
The trade was the decision was we
want to get to the moon as fast as
possible. And for that, you need a
really big rocket for you
to get the thrust that you need.
You just can't put the reusable
components into the vehicle to be
able to recover it afterwards.
NASA's has contracted with SpaceX X
for the Artemis program with plans
to use its starship launch vehicle
still in development to take humans
from a lunar outpost to the moon's
surface and eventually on to Mars.
Do you think NASA's role is always
going to be to build and launch
rockets, or is that going to be
outsourced, so to speak, to
other companies that seem to be
doing it quicker and more often?
I think we would definitely be very
much a part of launching rockets
and building rockets. For sure the
Artemis Campaign for the Future has
us continuing to launch SLS
vehicles. So you got to think about
the whole Artimus campaign is
not just the SLS,
it's also all of the other
components that come with it.
Commercial companies supplying US
logistics or commercial companies
supplying US human landers,
supplying US deep space habitats.
And I think it's a good thing to
have a good combination
of our ability to go into space
and not make it all be one specific
way of doing it.
NASA already relies heavily on the
private sector, with private
companies designing and leasing the
agency much of its hardware.
But Poole says there's no reason
NASA can't take it a step further
and just use the space X Starship
to cover the entire journey from
Earth to the moon and eventually
Mars.
If the current NASA plan goes
ahead to have the
SpaceX starship actually
deliver the astronauts
from the lunar outpost in orbit
to the surface of the moon and bring
them back up.
That will be an even more dramatic
refutation of the idea that the
only NASA's should be doing space
transportation.
Poole says that instead of flying
its own missions, NASA should play a
more limited and supportive role.
The future NASA role that that
makes the best sense is
research and development in
advancing science,
helping with the development
of new orbital
telescopes and things.
Doing research that will
assist the private
companies.
Visiting the Kennedy Space Center,
it's easy to be nostalgic for the
glory days of the space program,
but the effort to relive them with
Artemis has been a costly mistake.
Commercial space travel is the next
frontier, and it may be coming
sooner than we think.
You look at what's going on in the
private and there are more private
launch startups of all sizes
going on, raising venture capital
today between the Defense Department
having successes with with launches
from Space X and presumably
other other companies.
Space transportation
should be within
a decade or so, it's
possible to be the the main
model for how we get
people and things into space.
And that would be an incredible
sea change.
I'm telling you, we've never seen
such a tail
of flame.
And I have to say,
for what we saw tonight,
it's an A-plus.
Artemis one successfully launched.
How did you feel watching the
launch?
Mixed feelings.
The fact that it is a success, I
mean, assuming it completes the
mission and makes success,
then they plan
eight missions of this, which
means, you know, the 93 billion
only covers through 2024.
So the cost of this is going to be
several hundred billion if this
all goes through.
And so if there was a big failure
on the very first launch, there
would have been a chance to say,
well, look, all right, we
we we did this.
We built it.
It worked.
But we really don't want to do eight
of these. But to commit to eight
all eight launches now strikes
me as very foolish decision.
If there's one thing to be learned
from the history of technology, it's
that government support entails
hidden perils.
Paul wrote in Reason back in 1979
when heralding the dawn of private
ventures in space, like
with industries such as railroads,
cars, telecommunications, TV
and the power grid, space
exploration saw new dynamism once
the government backed off.
In the 50 years since NASA's
astronauts last walked on the moon,
remarkable progress made
by the private sector shows that
Poole was right back in 1979.
We can and should develop
space without government help.